[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
WhatsApp Prof
hello Walter
hi Martin are you well yes thank you
good good
we're on a
it seems like a broken record
the Pope's letter yes I'm sick and tired
of this letter but let's talk about this
we'll have to do it because this is one
of the things that's going to take us
through to the end so let's open with
the word of bread and I wish he will
read to the end of his letter and get on
with it
let's open
Heavenly Father
we thank you that you
have given us your word and that we can
see the signs around us
for the soon appearing of Our Lord we
ask that you Enlighten our minds and
guide this discussion again
and also the viewers with the Holy
Spirit in Jesus name amen amen
the letter Pope Francis call for Unity
around the climate crisis
and are we dealing with the climate hoax
how dare you even put up
such a title Martin it's just a question
so it's just a question
you see the problem is
on the one side you've got science
settled yes and then you've got to deal
with reality on the other side yes you
have the science that is settled
according to them and then you have the
real science
and never the twine shall meet never
so we'll have to look at what is it only
a scientific thing that we're dealing
with yes or is it something more so
modern there are people that are
that are telling us that this letter
this is of course
is so important for Humanity
and there are so many people that are on
this bandwagon that it seems as if
you're not going to stop this train it's
going to go wherever it wants
and there's that interesting Vision that
we read about in the spirit of prophecy
about this train with the full head of
steam
and uh Satan himself
sitting at the helm and steaming along
at a tremendous Pace yeah yeah well
let's see where he's taking the train
yes and then recently this letter that
we talking about is a movie that was
made about lodato see of course yes yeah
so that's what we're going to be
discussing so let's have a look at some
of the things that are relevant in that
letter
Toyota to see is a letter that Pope
Francis has written to you
that and that usually gets people
they're going
Francis didn't write me a letter I said
oh yes he did he wrote you a letter he
wrote every person on the planet a
letter
to share his concerns about the state of
the world it's that simple really it's a
letter from the Pope
we're going to be bringing together four
of the different voices that Pope
Francis is called specifically for in my
data scene
so we would like to invite in the name
of Pope Francis a few Representatives
the voice of the Curve peripheries
the voice of the indigenous peoples
the voice of the youth and also the
voice of nature of Wildlife
our idea is to invite all these people
bring them to the Vatican and then
having a dialogue together
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
among the 16 children who filed a
complaint to protest against the lack of
government action to tackle the climate
crisis I'm here because I want all the
global leaders to do something to stop
climate change because if it's not going
to be stopped it's going to harm our
future so if we want to stop global
warming we have to do something now
I won't let this fight die down trust me
organization
and now release it
every single time when I talk to the
kids
okay the one thing that I found common
amongst all our stories is that climate
change has impacted and is still
impacting our life in one way or the
other
Dear Mother Earth I am raising my voice
against the polluters the policy makers
and the governments who are responsible
for this destruction
we youth must bring a positive change to
heal you to save you and to save your
beauty as well as our future
as ecologists we look at nature as
species organisms that are interacting
problems like climate change disrupt
these interactions between species
these Marine heat waves are causing an
unknown amount of death among corals but
we did learn in 2015 that we lost at
least 25 percent of our corals Statewide
by July 2019 we started seeing this heat
wave arriving again
well Martin the first thing that I want
to say
is that it is propaganda at its best
and the target groups as we have seen
are impressionable Minds
like the youth for example
and of course the sentiment of the
indigenous people and their natural
environment in which they operate
and all of these things yes the poor and
the poor
but what he left out is the voice of
serious scientists who are not working
on models but on reality
and they're not working on Graphics that
are supposed to
affect Minds
and of course the religion plays a very
important part
and praying to Mother Earth
might help they think but Mother Earth
consists of Sand and Stone she doesn't
have ears she doesn't have a mouth she
doesn't have a brain
there is someone who transcends all of
those things
and that deity is not spelled with a
small letter G but with a capital letter
G yeah
and the thing also is
the movie
is playing a lot on your emotions it's
all it's all about emotion
and of course they keep playing the same
drum
yeah they'll show a flood
they could show a flood from a hundred
years ago in fact they could show one
from four and a half thousand years ago
that is a climatic change such as the
world has never seen
they don't have photographs of it but
they have record of it in the fossil
record which of course is reinterpreted
as a lot of nonsense
uh you know all these fossils are stream
orientated but they are supposed to be
chants
occurrences then why do all the animals
fall over in the same direction and
would like to ask
and and there are many things that we
could talk about and then the the same
drum it's it's a rising sea Waters
or what the the Meltdown will do when
the ice melts Etc
and the only contribution to sea water
rise that you could get is glaciers on
land
but any ice that would melt let's say
for example on the ice sheets on the
ocean wouldn't increase the sea level
one iota because ice is expanded water
and when it melts down it goes back to
contracted water so it doesn't add one
iota so you can try that in your glass
of water
put a lot of ice in it yeah and then
measure the level and then let the ice
melt and measure the level again and see
if your glass is Fuller because the ice
is melted and the answer is no
so there is a lot of perception
hype and you know the the melting of the
glaciers which is a seasonal thing
it comes again and again and again for
hundreds and hundreds of years they love
to show when it crashes and melts
but they they forget to show when it
increases again in the winter yeah so
all of these things and they love of
course the the coral reefs and we've
spoken about it so many times but let's
just for the sake of argument because
the last argument that we've seen now in
the video
says 2015 and 19 these heat waves killed
all these corals they killed all the
corals we have a terrible crisis ahead
of us now here's an article from August
2022 that's pretty current right
parts of the Great Barrier Reef show
highest Coral covers seen in 36 years
so Martin somebody is lying
or even if they're not lying they're
misinformed or they're distorting the
the information
two-thirds of the Great Barrier Reef in
Australia recorded the highest amount of
coral cover in nearly four decades so
that's and that's not actually some
parts no it's two-thirds of though grief
correct so we don't have to read at all
we're just throwing it in there
something is terribly wrong we have to
compare
what's being propagated in this movie to
reality yes so let's just have a look at
some of these things and see whether
this is actually propaganda
whether it is an emotional tune that
they are playing is it a religion
certainly seems like a religion because
they're praying to all kinds of deities
and they love the eagle of course
which was a symbol of Rome Just for
interest sake
so let's have a look at some more media
propaganda and see what they are trying
to tell us
and it starts off with it is important
that all the parties get to join the
conversation everybody has to be on
board how important is it to them that
everybody is on board well that is
showing you if there's a plan
nobody is excluded out of this plan okay
so nobody is excluded and another issue
that's very important is if you're going
to have a plan
that's going to unite
political entities
that is going to unite the various
structures of society whether it is the
the youth the family or the community
and whether you're going to unite all
the religions it'll have to be a neutral
compound that's it that cannot be
otherwise exactly it can incorporate the
religious but also the irreligious
correct so it must be it must be neutral
and climate change is neutral
because you you cannot couple it to one
particular religion for example so
Martin
if you read the book of Revelation and
you read about the the plagues that are
coming
there's definitely going to be some
climate change definitely and how much
of the world will be destroyed not by
climate change but by plagues basically
the whole world
the modern every living thing in the sea
died for example is one of the results
you know what if you are propagating a
lie
then maybe God will say okay I'll give
you the LIE yeah is that possible well
let's have a look at this and then we'll
talk about it it includes not just
private sector and civil society and
governments and multilateral development
Banks but youth are extremely important
in this equation
in cop27 I really hope that young people
will be more involved youth have to be
at the center of this kind of
implementation the youth engagement we
have to take it to the next level
trusting us does worth it we want to
prove that in the coke 27 because young
people are a Region's greatest resource
on the road to cop27 we need the youth
because whatever we do today for cop27
and cop 28 will be for them we'll be
working tirelessly to make sure that as
many young people as possible will be
trained and prepared to meaningfully
participate and collaborate with the
parties and governments at cop we look
forward to welcoming all of you in
Sharma Sheikh
U.S Special Envoy John Kerry is just
weeks from the cop 27 U.N climate Summit
in Egypt as scientists warn the world is
still on course for catastrophic
temperature rises he needs all the
momentum he can get right now every
government in the world is off course
every one of the 20 largest economies of
the world that represent 80 percent of
all the emissions are off Target at this
moment
new prime minister Rishi sunak won't be
much help he's just announced he won't
even be going to the summit all the more
reason to push for King Charles to
attend despite then prime minister Liz
truss reportedly asking him not to I
think it would be very powerful I know
that his being there would make a
difference sure because he has
credibility because he's been a
long-term leader
well of course things have changed sunak
will be attending is of course a world
economic Forum man
and has very good connections with the
digital transition in terms of money
he's the the right man for their job
that they have unfortunately we have all
the important people that are talking
about it Kerry for example King Charles
III you know the bones men of the world
belong to the secret society chapter 333
and all of these interesting people and
then King Charles of course is heavily
involved in all the secret societies as
a member of the order of the Garter his
uh yeah a member of the bath he is in
fact the Grand Master of many of these
so we are well supplied with secret
society members who have a certain
agenda that is totally contrary to what
the Bible is saying and it isn't it
interesting once you see this and you
see what the agenda so they've got an
agenda they have an agenda for sure that
we know now we have to look at what they
in the public eye are busy with yes
obviously you can see what that's where
that's going so now I don't understand
facetious or sound mean or anything like
that but they are really pushing the
youth angle
now when uh
Solomon's successor his son
consulted the elders as to what should
be done exactly in terms of certain
disenfranchised members of society
who did he listen to did he listen to
the elders or did he listen to the youth
he even asked the elders but when he
listened to the youth he took there he
took their advice and this is a strategy
that is very common
and uh you know it takes a certain
amount of experience
in the world to be able to discern
between hype and propaganda yeah and
it's it's very useful to them to engage
the energy of the youth
because propaganda can easily sway them
now fortunately there are quite a number
of youthful people
that are making reasonable comparisons
that's it that's not
letting themselves be indoctrinated the
whole time yes
now Martin what is the greatest
Safeguard against indoctrination
studying your Bible
studying the Bible does the bible want
about these things yes and if the whole
world jumps onto a bandwagon and says
let's go
is that a time to say or yes let's run
with it or is it a time to study your
Bible go back to the Bible whenever
there's a trend
go and see if it's biblical and nine out
of ten times if it's not 99 out of 100
times
or even higher you will find that the
trend
cannot be right no if you take for
instance Revival in
a religious
aspect
Satan is so clever there will be a
latter rain and that will be a Revival
but look at all the pre-false revivals
that he's planning and the false OS has
to come before the real yeah
so now it seems that he's going to
attend the cop 27 climate Summit in
Egypt next week
after number 10 previously said he was
too focused on the domestic economy to
attend and banned King Charles from
going
now is it the the tail wagging the dog
or the dog wagging the tail
and of course number 10 is going now and
it's going to the Ten Commandments and
we have the whole circus ready the new
10 climate Commandments and we have all
our bondsmen together and our secret
society order of the bath members over
there
uh order of the Garter members
and World economic Forum members the
modern how much trust would you put in
all these secret society members well I
won't put much trust how much trust will
you put in uh I wouldn't trust them
further than I can pick up and throw the
Empire State Building
okay that's good
well if you take another thing just to
think about
that's a it's really putting it out in
the media this thing oh now he's going
uh King Charles is not going it's
actually hyping up and putting it uh
drawing attention too yes by saying I'm
not going you rile up everybody like
Greta tunberg and the youth why are the
leaders not taking part and now they
succumb to the pressure and there they
go and eventually they will make
wonderful decisions and some people that
didn't even notice this would now say
okay but what's going on at goptoness
and this morning over the news I heard
that the the poorer countries were
saying things are moving in the right
direction that cop 27 the Richer nations
are going to pay for the transition of
the young of the of the poorer Nations
Martin is there such a thing as a richer
Nation or is everybody so indebted that
not everybody is poor true it's
nightmare the amount of debt there's no
not one country that's solvent how rich
is the United States of America with its
trillions and trillions of dollars of
debt it's bankrupt bankrupt so how will
they bail out the others by making more
money just preventing it so let's listen
to the other side of the story because
there are always two sides of the story
psychologist fragile Shaman she's a
senior lecturer at the University of the
Sunshine Coast she and a university
colleague of hers a professor they've
now diagnosed my condition it's the
nihilism they've done that after
interviewing 390 fellow sufferers
Skeptics have found on social media
somehow the headline alone to her
article tells you that my mind is
misfiring it's sleep frogging all over
the park
it's reads you know Inside the Mind of a
skeptic the mental gymnastics of climate
change denial
now Sherman does admit to one thing that
she did get wrong right she says she she
didn't expect this she says it's
contrary to her predictions but
oh dear you know people with higher
analytical abilities she says we're even
more likely to be skeptical
I mean how are we going to save this
planet if people keep up asking
questions like uh you know will this do
any good really is this really with the
pain are you sure Australia's emissions
really could make a difference things
like that
stop after two years of flooding rains
it is the last thing those in the flood
zone will be wanting to hear but the
Bureau of meteorology has officially
called the third consecutive La Nina
summer
but getting much more rain
and for three years in a row now
but how can that be because I remember
14 years ago reading that the drought we
had then would never break and this same
Bureau was then saying that the drought
would be a new climate
well Tim Flannery later her first
climate change commissioner he claimed
this in 2007.
even the reign of Falls isn't actually
going to fill our dams and our river
system
but
Shaman very clever psychologist she has
an answer she says these doubts of mine
they just result she says from a basic
misunderstanding of model-based climate
projections
there you go now what we're dealing with
here is anarchy on the most
extraordinary level in the last week
we've had protesters spraying orange
paint on car show rooms the bank of
England MI5 you know it's an all-out
assault not just by the way on the use
of fossil fuels I mean look at the
Melbourne cup instance where the guy
says he's doing it to stop the addiction
of gambling so whatever is uppermost in
their mind whatever moral Vision they
wish to impose upon the rest of us
apparently they can behave as they like
in some ways you can't blame the poor
Darlings because they've been
brainwashed at school brainwashed at
University told to bow down before the
goddess Greta the greatest physicist and
scientist the world has seen since the
rise at Newton and no one's told them no
one's told them that only three percent
of global CO2 is produced by and and the
case of Australia and my country the UK
too we are less than one percent of that
nobody has told them this at any point
in their lives and this is what you get
when you have a total failure of the
education system when it becomes
indoctrination rather than teaching
critical thinking you get this kind of
mad behavior well I think what
government now needs to do is to be
really tough on these people
what he said to that Martin
it just shows you I mean the length that
these people that are being it's like he
said brainwashed go to damaging
property even spraying an oil-like
substance that they are complaining
about on that but then he at the end
said
government should take action but they
all part of this governments are on this
bandwagon now Martin I have never
understood their CO2 argument
if I may be blunt I think it is a brain
dead argument it is because CO2 is the
common emission of every living creature
in the animal kingdom
and CO2 is the food of every plant-based
creature or organism on the entire
planet
so if I can ask you
if there's more CO2 emission from the
animal and plants will be so happy you
have more plants this is so ridiculous
then you have of course the CO2 sink
which is the ocean because there's an
equilibrium about we've said this many
many times it is a cycle that has been
introduced from the beginning it is a
god-given cycle and these people who
want to break the cycle
it is excuse me in my opinion idiotic
it makes absolutely no sense one
volcanic eruption will put more CO2
emission into the atmosphere than the
entire world would be able to produce in
a year
it is that ridiculous so the equilibrium
that is in nature with CO2 is a is a god
designed equilibrium
to remove the emissions you would have
to stop
doing whatever Humanity does
and you would have to stop breathing
exactly now the way to stop breathing is
to well to die get rid of humanity then
you will have gotten a lot of CO2
emission out of the way
whether that is a plan or not well that
is a big discussion in the world the the
Georgia Guidestones before they were
blown up told us exactly what our sea
Christian had to say about that and
we've already said what we think are sea
Christian stands for
so Martin this is a philosophy that can
only come from another source and that
definitely doesn't come from God no and
if there's something so false trying to
get Humanity to do something obviously
there's a bigger agenda behind this
there must be an agenda and they cannot
find a culprit they kept looking for a
culprit then it was you know ozone
destruction
by the gases that you have in
refrigerators it was wonderful for the
industry because everything had to be
changed you've never heard about it
again
uh ever since then and all of these
other things what about the destruction
of the environment by spraying
aluminum-based products into the
atmosphere what about all of those
things with that can be can be measured
to destroy crop formation for example
which has absolutely nothing to do with
climate change but with
deliberate interference so there are
many many things woe to those who
destroy the Earth
now there are bodies and people and
religious systems woe to those that
destroy the Earth you would have to
include anyone that breathes that's it
that's what they do yes they include
that now humanity is actually the
problem it is that's the enemy of nature
correct and by the way fossil fuels
where do they come from Modern from out
of earth oh how did they get there well
because of the flood uh-huh so that is
buried organic material
so in other words that carbon was locked
up where in the animal and plant kingdom
before and now it is available to be
used it could be again put into the
plant and animal kingdom if you allowed
things to to happen naturally there are
things that are destructive yeah we have
of course like destroying the lungs of
the Earth the the Amazon for example
and all of those things of course it is
important that we look at the
environment but if you have a CO2
problem plant a tree that's it
Martin if everybody planted a tree how
many trees would we have seven and a
half billion at least uh
so let's have a look at their so-called
data that is based on models and reality
the two are as far removed as the East
is from the West
so let's look at Florida land falling
hurricanes have we heard a lot about
hurricane destruction in Florida
and you know what when I read the news
these days
and they have climate warm warnings like
hurricane warnings
they always predict the worst
they're keeping the hype at the highest
possible level exactly they don't say
there's a storm developing but it will
probably dissipate
there's a storm developing it probably
won't make landfall no they all are
going to make landfall and they're all
going to increase in going to be the
worst ever it's going to be the worst
ever now every now and then one does
make landfall and you have a lot of
Destruction it's been like that for a
long long time
so here is a graph on Florida
landfalling hurricanes over the years
and this goes back to the 1800s to the
present time
and you can see that the peaks in the
past were higher and that there's
actually a decline
Now isn't that the opposite of what they
are saying yeah because every time
there's one that's landfalling then this
is this is the ultimate and it's getting
worse and it's been uh and then they say
it climate change is the cause and it is
getting more frequent and worse than
previously now here you have Florida
land falling hurricanes you have normal
ones and major hurricanes the blue line
and the red line over here
and if you go back to the 1800s look at
where those Peaks were
Martin was that climate change that was
the very beginning of the Industrial
Revolution
and had absolutely nothing to do with
climate change
and it's been like this and even lower
over time
and presently well
it's lower than it was in the past
so again the science of reality is if
you put it into juxtaposition with the
models we have an opposite story yeah
and then you have land falling U.S
hurricanes and major hurricanes and
again we can see that in the past the
levels were higher
and that the average is sort of in this
region over here and at the moment we're
actually lower
so Martin
how do these two gel
that's a problem if you don't see see
the other side you only believe the one
narrative
all right
what about the effect of geoengineering
shall we have a look at that
perhaps the greatest lie ever
perpetrated on populations all over the
world is the condensation Trail lie what
we're seeing in our skies is not
condensation it's sprayed particulate
dispersions with very few exceptions
they shouldn't be there jet engines burn
clean so if there's anything coming out
of them it's an additive
foreign
this engine a high bypass turbofan jet
engine this is the engine that is on all
military takers and all commercial
carriers is in essence a jet powered fan
ninety percent of the air that moves
through this engine is non-combusted
this engine by Design is nearly
incapable of producing any condensation
Trail except under rare and extreme
circumstances and again
and we have film footage of aircraft
flying at altitude with nozzles visible
turning on and off
that is the end of the argument
in the foundation for the development of
a weather satellite
will permit man to determine the
world's Cloud layering
and ultimately to control the weather
and he who controls the weather will
control the world
the Air Force has gotten Great Value out
of harp in the past we we took over from
the Navy and Managed IT and actually did
a number of experiment campaigns up
there and have finished our our work
that we're interested in doing up there
we've uh moving on to other ways of uh
managing the ionosphere which the harp
was really designed to do was to inject
energy into the ionosphere be able to
actually control it and but that work is
has been completed
now people will say that these web pages
are conspiratorial
now those streams that come out of the
back or they also conspiratorial Martin
they probably will say that they will
probably say that but at the same time
they have all of this technology to
change the weather you know what's a sad
part
it's conspiratorial until they admit it
what do they say then then you have a
problem then you don't hear about it
anymore because that guy this that was
they were working with harp for instance
harp has been in the Forefront of people
saying oh it's conspiracy theorists
conspiratorial and all of this they've
admitted all the things that they were
accused of of
manipulating the ionosphere yes but now
people they just no we don't know they
can even produce earthquakes I mean
Tesla produced an earthquake by accident
and uh they they it caused one in New
York they was busy with his experiments
and they have that technology and they
are suddenly capable of using that
technology
all right let's just let's just go on a
little bit of a spiritual angle
A house divided against itself will not
stand
is that what the Bible says yes
how can two walk together if they unless
they're great agree A house divided
against each other will not stand
and terrible will be the crash if it
were so
now when Jesus was here and the devil
tempted him in the wilderness of
Temptation did he take him to a very
high mountain and show him oh how many
how many or all the kingdoms of the
world
and offered them to him if he would bow
down to him yep
and he refused
right correct he refused to bow down
because you shall Worship the Lord thy
God and him only shall you serve now
imagine the arrogance
of taking away or assuming to own that
which he usurped in the first place
I mean he is so arrogant
now those are whose kingdoms according
to him he's his kingdom now Martin what
if these kingdoms are ideologically
totally different
in terms of their culture in terms of
their religion in terms of their
philosophy let us say that these
cultures are totally totally different
is there then A House Divided yes
apparently apparently apparently okay
okay
so there's only there's only one
possibility here
or maybe two the one possibility as I
see it is that Satan has lost control
over everything and everything's gone
Haywire
the second possibility there's method in
his Madness
order of cow aha all right so the
religious divide
the one country is a Muslim country the
other country is a Christian country
let's create extremist groups in both of
them and let's create chaos until
Humanity cannot take the chaos anymore
and let's make them feel the pain
has he done that yes has he done that in
the political sphere has he done that in
the military sphere has he done that in
the economic sphere everywhere has he
done that in the religious sphere
has he done that in the philosophical
sphere do we have different philosophies
in different parts of the world
do some Nations say we will only serve
this religion do they make it a state
religion yes do they have terrorists
that will want to destroy anyone who is
not in harmony with that yes yes who is
now trying to bring them all together
supposedly actually himself
and who's he using the pope okay so
who's instigating all of these things
didn't they say wouldn't it be wonderful
if the pope were at cop 27 Oh for
certain that's why we've got we're doing
this episode on the letter because
everything is about La dato C and that
actually is all right him getting so did
he get all the economic world to come
and sign in accord with them yes did he
get the religious world just recently at
Kazakhstan to sign a document that they
are all to accept each other's Creeds
without any argument who created the
creeds
Satan Satan
Satan created the creeds
is he a great friend of the Bible no
does he yeah it's a poor contempt upon
it
didn't the Jesuit call it that poisonous
ASP
the received text didn't they call it
the poisonous ass yes oh that's why I
love the received text it must be the
truth the Jesuits hated whatever the
Jesuits hate I must love
do they love climate change
yeah so I must hate it why
because it's not true
and because they're cooking up some plan
with it so there's a there's a plan
there's an agenda do we have to look
behind the scenes for everything so it's
not a house divided no so it has a plan
and this plan is to unite Humanity
against those that believe that word
that's it right because where does
climate change start actually in
evolution because those that believe
that word will stand by that word
they will not pick up arms to go and
Destroy someone but they will use their
voice and their tongue to proclaim the
message because that is a command in the
Bible
go ye into all the world and preach the
gospel
but you will tread on serpents doesn't
it say so
yep you will tread on serpents you will
tread on scorpions do they sting and
bite
so is there going to be a war an
ideological war yes so Martin the world
is divided
but it is divided by Design
exactly because the one who claims
ownership
is like a mega company that has a
thousand products on the market
vying for market share
advertising against each other but all
belonging to the same company that's it
that's how it works
so let's look again at some of their
claims
their claims are there will be massive
massive ice sheet destruction
well here's an article from the 2nd of
October 2020 climate bombshell
Greenland ice sheet recovers as
scientists say earlier loss was due to
Natural warming not CO2 omissions
isn't that the opposite of what they are
singing direct opposite so if you repeat
a lie often enough
will there be takers if you take all
these people that we've showed well in
that video in the movie all those young
people
Greta and this new lady
all of them have they seen this
do you think they've actually seen this
they will describe
because it doesn't rhyme with their
narrative yeah
so in the scientific World scientists
are scrambling to understand what
natural causes lie behind the sudden
Slowdown
in Greenland's summer warming and Ice
loss dating back to 2010.
such findings play Havoc with the
simplistic settled science notion that
carbon dioxide produced by humans
burning fossil fuels is the main if not
only driver of global temperature
warming or Cooling
button how much carbon emission is there
during a forest fire
tons tons
okay so a notion that leads many green
activists to complain that the climate
will stop changing if Society signs on
to the Net Zero CO2 emissions agenda Net
Zero CO2 means you have to stop
breathing exactly there's Net Zero CO2
there's no life
so you have all of these green people
that are involved now there was a speech
in the European Parliament the other day
where the one politician said quite
bluntly
the only Greenie that he respects is
Kermit the Frog
here's a graph of the Arctic sea ice
extent area of ocean with at least 15
percent sea ice
and if we go from June to July August
September October and you look at the
various years
2022 and you go back to
2012 1981
etc etc to a 2010 is the median
and look at the graphs modern what has
changed over the years
it's the same pattern exactly over and
over then it goes down a little bit then
it comes up the problem is they said oh
no it's going down and it's going to
disappear so it seems as if there are
Cycles on Earth
and some of these Cycles run in uh
yearly Cycles some of them run in seven
year cycles and some over longer periods
you have various Cycles so let's say you
have a cycle of drought
that can last for seven years
or three-year Cycles and then you come
out of the cycle so like we saw in that
video previously there was this
prediction that the deserts would stay
and that would be the new Norm
and now we are in a flood cycle so the
desert is gone and we're not drowning
and then in the next seven year cycle
we're going to a dry cycle again
in my life I have experienced those
Cycles in the country where I live
exactly and they will continue now if I
go to the Bible where there are seven
year cycles and three and a half year
cycles of drought for example without
any rain yeah and then a small black
cloud appeared and I hear the sound of
an abundance of rain so where there's
Cycles then now who who induced those
Cycles well guarded God there now do you
think he put natural cycles into the
world as well did he put natural
seven-year Cycles into into things in
the world yes and did he say if you
would keep a Sabbath year things would
recover for example so Cycles have been
part and part parcel of Humanity's
existence
is it easy for them
if they have an agenda yeah
that if you're going into a cycle of
drought or if you are going into a cycle
of more rain than usual to make a big
climate issue out of it definitely
but are they doing it they are doing it
but then you have to have an agenda
because you have to put it so that
people don't realize they're being duped
so that will that's why if it was just
normal and they were not part busy with
an agenda they would acknowledge uh okay
no this is not two like like the news
that we showed it in the previous
WhatsApp Prof where they said oh this is
the greatest heat wave that England has
ever had and then we showed a news
broadcast paper a newspaper article of
the previous years where it was even
hotter yeah it was just in a generation
in a previous generation so this
generation wouldn't realize it all right
so the world economic Forum if you see
that name
what side of the agenda will they be on
definitely are not on God's side Kermit
the Frog they'll be on the green side
except Kermit the Frog speaks sense
every now and then
let's have a look at what they have to
say
the extreme weather events that the
scientists have long connected to the
climate crisis are becoming far more
frequent and far more destructive for
150 years we built up a world based on
the assumption that we can exploit the
planet for free and it translates to
very dramatic impacts happening right as
we speak the climate crisis is a threat
multiplier which means it exacerbates
existing inequities in our society the
impacts are felt most deeply by black
indigenous and communities of color we
know that this transition we require a
fast adoption of a lot of new
technologies and the question today is
how to find the appropriate way to
finance this technology they put a
number around it it's an extra two and a
half to three trillion dollars a year of
additional finance that we have to find
in order to get those emissions down
racial CNN's a global news provider and
you operate in many different markets
with many different types of Regulation
you know what's your kind of perspective
on that issue about the kind of Primacy
if you like of the first amendment in
terms of the global speech environment
there was just a study yesterday that we
wrote about on CNN it was a News Guard
study of Tick Tock that found that in
searches for uh basic information about
news stories in 20 percent nearly 20
percent of videos contain search results
with misinformation and that was on
everything from the 2020 U.S
presidential election to the Russia
Ukraine war to misinformation about
abortion so there is an issue where a
platform is acting as a provider of
information and a young audience is
coming to that looking for information
perhaps not equipped to sort through not
media literate enough to sort through
what is and isn't correct and this is
what they're finding so to me the
discussion really has to stay in that
space not so much what can be said and
not can be said but how are we handling
the information and what are we putting
out what is getting promoted what is
right rising to the top so that when
users and particularly young users are
searching for it what are they coming
across
you know we partnered with Google for
example if you Google climate change
you will at the top of your search you
will get all kinds of un resources
we started this partnership when we were
shocked to see that when we'd Googled
climate change we were getting
incredibly distorted information right
at the top so we we're becoming much
more proactive you know we own the
science and we think that the world you
know should know it and and the
platforms themselves also do but again
it's it's it is um it's it's a huge huge
challenge that I think all sectors of
society need to be very active
so Martin they own the science
well we own the science that's what you
said
so now that might let you that might get
you thinking okay so if they own the
science are you not allowed to taste it
anymore or anything no they will they
will get Google and everybody else to
provide that information which they own
their signs so another thing that also
popped up 20 percent
is now according to them this
information
and young people get their information
from Tick Tock mostly and she was
mentioning Tick Tock as well
so at least there's 20 truth out there
Martin you must not be naughty this is
what the world economic forum is putting
up and they're showing worst case
scenarios of disasters happening do they
show that these things happened uh a
millennium ago or that they happened
whenever no did we have tsunamis
what happened in the great Lisbon
earthquake wasn't there a massive
tsunami that went across yeah and Europe
in that time
you know Martin
you could play this game any way you
want to and you see now just look at it
we've saw we saw the video with all this
actually this information in it but then
you got the news
people CNN for instance that lady is one
of the top people at CNN saying that
that is this that the other side is
disinformation so who's controlling the
media they are
you see the problem is CNN that lady she
says that they want the real information
out there their science their science
has to go out but are they practicing it
do they put it out there in a propaganda
way yes that's what we have to and I'm
amazed that they they're still in that
previous one we saw use Al Gore quite a
lot now if we look up his secret society
track record
it's uh it also reads makes very
interesting reading so let's just see
what they said about how they want to do
it on CNN and other forums
CNN's technical director Charlie Chester
said the media company's next Focus will
quote that they will beat to death like
they did with the pandemic yeah will be
climate change let's take a look we're
going to start focusing mainly on
climate
um
climate like global warming and like
that's going to be our next like
um
it's gonna be our Focus like uh like our
Focus was to get Trump out of office
right without saying it that's what it
was right so our next thing is going to
be for climate change awareness so
that's like the next
like story like that will yeah that will
will be to death but that one's got
longevity you know what I mean it's not
like
there's a definitive ending to the
pandemic or you know like it'll taper
off to a point that it's you know not a
problem anymore probably think it's
Gonna Take Years so they'll probably be
able to milk that quite a bit
well there you have it out of the mouth
of the technical director of CNN and I
think he gathers his inspiration from
what's in his gloss there
as thou drinkest so thou thinkers
isn't there something like Babylonian
wine yes beer qualified for Babylonian
wine I'm sure he does I'm sure it does
you see that when we're sitting at we've
got these people they talking they're
giving you a talk they want to put truth
and they own the science and then they
want to do it in a way that oh we'll
beat it to death that's what they're
going to do and it's nauseating
now Martin can they use the media to
show things as worse than they actually
are yes and pick up hype and sentiment
definitely ah whip up the emotions this
one's very interesting let's just look
what they're doing and how they do it
the weather channel is now responding to
reports that one of their reporters was
essentially faking it during his
coverage of hurricane Florence probably
seen the video on Facebook as that
reporter struggles to keep his balance
okay uh picking it up here
and Wilmington North Carolina right at
the intercoastal and we're in one of
these bands so now a spokesperson for
the weather channel is defending Seidel
saying it's important to note that the
two individuals in the background are
walking on concrete while Seidel tries
to maintain his footing on wet grass the
spokesperson goes on to say Seidel was
exhausted after reporting on air until
1am
get the wins down below tomorrow
I mean it's going to come right down
through these buildings and I mean
there'll be something or anything just
higher you know by two times just
because of the way that it's funneling
through those buildings so that's what
we're gonna have to watch out for
there's a lot of Windows there's a lot
of pieces of debris certainly flying
around so guys we will absolutely uh do
our best to bring you coverage as long
as soon
well Martin
I remember as a young child walking in
Cape Town
against the black Southeastern and you
really had to brace yourself and hold on
to a pole every now and then
and I think climate change has gone into
reverse it was much worse when I was
when I was young you know I was small
and I was easily blown over now I'm not
so easily blown over so I think the
winds have gotten a lot less but I think
that blown over is also meaning mentally
probably now
modern you get lies
and then you get more lies and then you
get these lies manufactured lies that
yes it's to and this is just again I to
show
you've got we've started off with the
movie the letter that tells you climate
it's a nightmare
and then you got the CNN side the media
telling you no this is we own the
science we need to get this out but then
you get this false information thrown at
you the whole time all right but
fortunately we have saviors that will
bring us the truth like Elon Musk he's
gonna set Twitter right and you're going
to have only truth right
so Elon Musk has taken control of
Twitter and fired its top Executives
because they were heavily into
censorship yes
censoring political ideologies censoring
presidents censoring whoever they want
misinformation
everything's going to come right now
right
so Elon Musk has completed his 44
billion deal to buy Twitter a source
familiar with the deal told CNN Thursday
putting the world's richest man in
charge of one of the world's most
influential social media platforms
perhaps most immediately many will be
watching to see how soon musk could let
former president Donald Trump back on
the platform
as he has previously said he would do
depending on the timing such a move
could have major implications for the
upcoming U.S midterm elections as well
as the 2024 presidential campaign in
taking those steps musk could
single-handedly upend the media and
political ecosystems reshape public
discourse online and disrupt The Descent
sphere of conservative leaning social
media properties that emerge largely in
response to grievances about bans
restrictions on Twitter and other
mainstream Services Martin did he go and
visit the Pope
just before he took over Twitter did the
executives of Google and all the other
Medias also go and same place visit the
Pope
EU official warns musk he'll have to fly
by our rules as he buys Twitter
so when he tweeted the bird is freed in
response Britain quote tweeted musk
saying in Europe the bird will fly by
our rules
so Martin who makes the rules mask or
the people behind the scene that's where
it gets to they always have a front
company or a front man that has to take
all of this I mean
and apparent Freedom that's it
whereas you have actual
censorship I don't think there's any
form of media or all of any of this in
that's not manipulated
all right now here we have pictures of
musk in his Halloween costume
and apparently this costume costs
and on his chest he has the goat with an
upside down cross on it now this could
all be a joke of course
but it could also show
an allegiance to certain groupings or
ideologies it could be a joke let's
leave it out there for people to decide
for themselves but this is no joke he
and his sons appearing
with the Pope
and why do they all have to go to the
pub who wrote The Letter dippo the pope
wrote the letter
who has to dance according to the
letters tune everybody else everybody
else so Martin because the letter was
written for all Humanity all Humanity
correct now if you read your Bible and
you know who wrote The Letter mutton if
you've got a letter
in the post which said to you
this is a letter for your instruction
written by the Antichrist
would you do it would you be enthused
and say wow let's do this
maybe when you if you were dressed like
this you would but if you studied your
Bible where would you categorize the
papacy
at that side on that side the enemy side
yeah now according to the scripture who
gave him his power and great Authority
the dragon the dragon and according to
scripture who is the dragon
Satan
so if you got a letter hmm
with a stamp on it from an from a goat
with an upside down cross on it
saying that this is a letter from the
dragon through his mouthpiece the Beast
would you jump and do what you are told
no
Martin you are antisocial what's wrong
with you it's a problem I got a letter
from another place ah you have another
letter yeah
you have this letter
have you read the book of Revelation yes
uh are there letters in it yes to
churches there are letters written to
churches is there a letter written to
larizia actually the letters to the
churches yes into ladies letters to
humanity
so these are to humanity why does nobody
make a hype about those letters but this
other letter is on every media and every
platform that you can imagine
just in a little interesting side note
here the
spaceship that musk built that's taking
people up and down is the Dragon
oh just for interesting just for
interesting well Martin if you put those
two together then they make sense
because uh according to the scriptures
he is receiving his marching orders and
his instructions you better stay in
harmony with those what happened to you
in the Middle Ages if you crossed this
organization
you were tortured are we on the brink of
the same situation again if you look at
when you differ from the narrative
especially the climate change narrative
how you are being ostracized and how
they they won't mind you being
uh tortured to get your head right into
their opinion so they might do some
waterboarding to see have you you know
if you go to the medieval places and you
look at the torture instruments that
they used I have so many pictures of
them I've been in so many of them
and when I was in Nuremberg at the Town
Hall
where the the beasts of Revelation are
portrayed
and we asked the people that's an old
video of ours as they walk by what do
these things mean nobody knew nobody
nobody no matter what educational
echeloni came from and eventually we
knocked on the door
and we asked for the guide who takes you
around and shows you the medieval
torture chambers Etc and we asked the
guide what do these things mean he
didn't have a clue he didn't have a clue
and it was put there so that Humanity
would not forget
but Humanity has forgotten
and humanity is being duped once again
into believing lies and propaganda
so let's just have a look at some more
media stories to see how they are
propagating their agenda
increase the
citizen that the Energy Information
Administration said as of October 14th
the U.S only had about a 25-day supply
you have the Northeast and New York
already rationing home heating oil
what are we doing to prepare for the
winter and to ramp up supply of diesel
I'll take the question on the diesel
because I just don't have the the data
on that in front of me so let me take
that and and we'll get back to you on
that but but writ large the president
has been working very very hard uh to
make sure that we're uh that not only
are are we ready for fluctuations that
could come and of course the prices are
going down and we think that's important
um but that we are also doing what we
can to help our European friends and
partners who are also going to be facing
a long cold winter we have doubled our
commitment the commitment he made in
March for natural gas exports to Europe
we've doubled that commitment
um in terms of actual you know getting
things over there getting natural gas
over there and we are working with
foreign suppliers of natural gas uh and
oil to see if we can't help our European
Partners diversify their own storage and
supplies I'm anxious to get your
thoughts on this New York Times report
that U.S officials thought they had a
deal with the Saudis before the
president went to Jetta inside Arabia
for his meeting with the Crown Prince
but they thought they had a deal on oil
supplies and oil price of oil but that
the Saudis backed out of that deal what
can you tell us about so we have been
very clear about how we believe uh parts
of that report was mischaracterized and
there has been some changes that have
been made to that report look we've also
been clear that our trip that the
president's trip to the Middle East was
not about oil
prices go down with the Saudis that the
Saudis then backed away from again the
trip was not about oil I have one final
when he closed down
would you close down I have a transition
from the oil industry yes
it is a big statement because I would
stop why would you do that because the
oil industry pollutes significantly I
see here's the deal but it's a big thing
well if you let me finish the statement
because it has to be replaced by
renewable energy over time over time and
I'd stop giving to the oil industry I'd
stop giving them Federal subsidies he
won't give Federal subsidies to the to
the gas and shashimi to the to solar and
wind yeah why are we giving it to oil
industry we actually do get the solar
and wind that's maybe the biggest
statement in terms of business that's
the biggest statement okay because
basically what he's saying is he is
going to destroy
the oil industry will you remember that
Texas would you remember that
Pennsylvania Oklahoma Vice President
Biden Q2 numbers
um for compared to last year the dark
brown the dark line is this year
compared to last year
seven look at the numbers drastic for
Exxon Chevron
shell BP just crushing profits that
they've had this year over last year it
is my profound Duty
to make it clear to the world
that losing emergency stuck may become
painful in the months to come
Martin the companies have got record
earnings
but the prices have soared and there's
no stock and there is no stock
the reason why there is no stock is
because they don't want stock
and he recently said the prices are
coming down when in actual fact I think
he's standing on his head because the
prices have gone up
just look at our country yes we have
increased by about what 50 70 percent
since the beginning of the year yes
and we are at record highs and then now
they also say there's going to be
shortages now what are they targeting
diesel that's it why diesel Martin
Farmers the oil industry and electricity
energy
now the interesting thing is that trucks
or anything that holds heavy weights
that has to run on diesel trains because
diesel gives you maximum torque at low
revs
whereas gasoline gives you maximum
torque at high rates so you cannot hold
things over Hills and over mountains and
pull heavy things behind you on high
Raves you have to pull it on low ribs
maximum torque and therefore the diesel
engine is the one that runs the truck
industry that runs any hauling industry
or any hard work industry
if you destroy that
you increase all prices across the board
and that's it because everything is
being hauled by diesel the food is being
taken to its
stores or wherever it shows run on
diesel everything runs on diesel so you
have to Target diesel is there an agenda
of course is it linked to climate change
all right that's
so now they're saying let's go to
electric vehicles
do you know that to produce the
batteries for the electric vehicles
takes more or produces more carbon
emission than the diesel engine would
produce
Universal you cannot produce the battery
without fossil fuels you cannot so the
production of the battery takes actually
more fossil fuels than you would use if
you used it in the vehicle in the first
place
so the argument is nonsensical and
reversed that's why there has to be an
agenda
so millions of britons at risk of
poverty cold home deaths as Energy
prices soar
so a British charity is warning millions
of people in the UK are at risk of
poverty and death
modern only the UK or the whole of the
cult country District in the entire
world the northern hemisphere of
actually yeah so ten thousand people die
every year in the UK directly because of
a cold home that number is going to
Skyrocket so they claim we're going to
have another cold homes epidemic across
the UK
it has a cost in mental health in in ill
health are they are they driving some
form of agenda it isn't it interesting
that two years ago we showed that deagle
report yes
and it wasn't because of
um war war not pandemics but could it
have been because of the so-called cures
for the pandemics could it have been
because of climate change could it have
been because of Industry manipulation or
there's no electricity gold no so
there's a few factors that is already
popping up but all are part of a
possible agenda all right there's
another question if there is a so-called
shortage
of fossil fuels then why is OPEC
reducing its production why did that
chick warn the world the waste for
instance are there profits down ah no no
not at all Martin there are people that
have studied these things and we're
going to look at the video now by
Professor Jonathan Dube
is from Israel
and he's going to talk about these
issues and we'll see that there is
another aspect about the climate change
issue and that is that you cannot
divorce it from the religious aspect
let's just have a look what he has to
say
I'm professor of theoretical physics and
chemistry at Ben Gurion University in
Israel I'm also a member of Vancouver
University's school for sustainability
and climate change and the school for
nanoscale Science and Technology also at
Bangor University I'm also one of the
founders of the Israeli forum for
rational environmentalism which is
basically a think tank advocating for
rational thinking in topics of climate
environment and energy there is no what
we would call in in science a Smoking
Gun evidence that CO2 is related even to
the majority of hitting we simply do not
know now this is something you know you
won't hear a lot of scientists say right
that they don't know it's it's like
confession of of um right yeah but
that's the honest truth it's a
complicated system we don't know and
there's actually the this is stated in
the ipcc reports in something called the
equilibrium climate sensitivity that's
the number that relates temperature to
CO2 and it's all over the place
and our estimations of the contribution
to CO2 hasn't changed from
1979. after billions of dollars invested
Into Climate science and it still hasn't
we don't know the answer I'm following
the system of these people the way they
think we're the enemy yes humans are now
the enemy I am I right I completely
agree with this
when you try to look at the root
philosophy behind the climate alarmism
what you find out
is that the ideal
is an unimpacted nature
Gaia
the environment you hear people talking
we must save the environment what is the
environment right it's an untangible
thing what is it so it has evolved into
a spiritual thing it is a spirituality
and a goddess in a way in a real way and
everything we do
is first measured not by how good it is
for humans how does it promote human
flourishing and human well-being but the
first thing it's measured by is is it
impacting the planet is it impacting the
environment are we changing Gaia of
course if you follow the logic of this
ideal
then clearly the Q
is that there will be no humans on the
planet right then the ideal is complete
now according to him
and Martin you say he's an atheist yes
diagnosis atheist agnostic
we have reversed something
we've placed the Earth
in the prime position and Humanity in
the secondary position what did God do
in Genesis he put Humanity in charge of
creation so we have a classic reversal
that's it and I have always maintained
that Satan is the master of reversal
he has changed the position
of the environment and Humanity
around he has changed the position of
male and female around
he has changed the hierarchy
around that's it he has placed the
children and the youth above the parents
in every single sphere he is being the
master of reversal
and as he rightly says if you're going
to make the Earth Paramount you have to
destroy Humanity you need to have
exactly like we said if you want to take
away
CO2 they cannot be Humanity now who
wants to this who's called the destroyer
in the Bible Satan Satan
I think with that we can rest our case
for the first half of this discussion
yeah because it this is just the first
portion of the letter that we've we've
discussed we cannot go through we cannot
do it in one session we'll have to do it
in two but Martin the world is on the
brink of the greatest catastrophe that
Humanity has ever experienced
because the Bible says there will be a
time of trouble such as never was who
introduces that time of trouble
Satan and when Humanity swallows the LIE
hook line and sinker
and acts upon it
then God will intervene and give them
the lie and give them the climate change
because they wanted to lie they can have
the LIE may God preserve us from lies
let us read the letter
that God has given us and ignore the
letter that comes out of the pen of the
Antichrist amen let's pray
Heavenly Father
the world is being duped
into following an agenda
but the ultimate agenda
is that Satan says Bow Down and Worship
and the Bible says whom you give
yourselves to obey whose servant you are
and there is an agenda
to make us bow down and serve an entity
that has
usurped
the position
of Christ
and Lord we want to acknowledge that we
want to bow down to none other
than the one who redeemed us
saved us from our situation and will
save us in future from this situation as
well this is my prayer in Jesus name
amen amen
thank you
foreign